High-intensity explosive tendon-stiffening protocol.
Every single word in this sentence is wrong.
I'll explain to you first what Yanis is definitely not doing, what he might be doing, but still why it's not optimal and can be done better.
This must be said first.
I really like Yanis.
His style, his approach to training, everything.
I have absolutely nothing against him, but I have seen on Reddit how much damage this post did to the community, because people's understanding of what he's doing, why he's doing it, and what it's for is at an absolutely minimal level.
Honestly, I joined a thread that had a few hundred comments, I think.
And I didn't go through every single one of them, but I checked them.
And there was one person, one person who understood what was going on and what Yanis was not doing.
So I need to address this issue, because it's not only different from what we believe, or what people believe it does, but it's also quite dangerous.
And why take the risk of doing something that won't benefit you at all?
Okay, so let's go word by word.
High intensity.
Okay, this is not high-intensity training.
Intensity means that you lift heavy.
It's not heavy.
Those hits are very, very light.
And what we know from the literature is that tendons adapt to load.
They adapt to stretch.
And the stretch is caused by load.
So, in general, everything you need to do to target your finger tendons is stretch them to the desired length, which you can do by loading them with high intensity, which is not the case here, or by giving it time, because when you contract your muscle-tendon unit, the muscle gets shorter over time
and the tendon stretches.
This is how those healing protocols, lasting sixty or thirty seconds, work.
Explosive, so high-intensity explosive.
It's not really explosive.
The hit is really fast because it mobilizes your motor units within a millisecond, okay?
But actually, to train our nervous system, you need an explosive move, and an explosive move in general doesn't matter whether it's eccentric, concentric, or isometric.
The main thing that came from all the studies I have seen is that the most important thing is the intention to be as fast as possible.
So in this situation, Yanis is not hitting as fast as he can.
Because if he did, he would obviously injure himself.
So it's not explosive by any means, okay?
Someone said it's isometrics.
It can also be discussed, but I'm just going to skip it.
Tendon-stiffening protocol.
Okay, so for sure, you're not doing anything right for your tendons or anything good, because as I said before, there is no intensity and there is no stretch.
What you do is introduce a very sharp, fast jerk, which your tendons don't like. They do not adapt this way. This is how you can damage them, but you can't make them stiffer. That's just it. It doesn't work like that. So, if the main goal is to target tendons and
despite the method being completely misunderstood, it's completely the opposite way.
What it actually does is mobilize your motor units, which are muscles, to respond very quickly to a light-load, low-intensity stimulus.
So, you will hit, right? Your muscles have to stabilize within a millisecond so your joint doesn't get injured. I actually injured my left wrist this way, because I wasn't hitting this way, but I just wanted to measure how fast this explosion was, because I also considered this way of training: how fast it is when I hit and when I just try to pull as fast as I can against an isometric hold.
And it was great.
It worked great.
The thing is that once I forgot to load my wrist before the hit, everything went to the ligament, and I have a small problem with the ligament.
That's why I can't pull on the left, because it keeps coming back.
So even if we think that, okay, this short stimulation will mobilize my nervous system to respond, you should do it from a loose position. But obviously, you can't do it from this position because you'll injure yourself, as I did in this situation, because I was hitting with about twenty kilos of back pressure. It's not dangerous if you're loaded, but if you're loaded, your response from the nervous system is already limited.
So, the things you need to do to make the exercise safe are actually contradictory to what you're trying to achieve, okay? So, the only thing it can do is, as I said, this nervous-system and muscle-response adaptation. And why is it not optimal? I gave you one reason, but I'm going to give you a few more. So, again, to mobilize all your units, all your muscles, as fast as you can, you need the intention of being as fast as possible, which is not the case. So, what you can do, I don't know, is take a ball and throw it in the air.
It's a ballistic way of doing that.
It works.
You can attach a chain to the wall.
You can pull.
Or you can put something here, right?
By the way, I'm just making this kind of tool that will let me really contract my muscles isometrically without this eccentric phase.
Because here, I don't believe it's eccentric.
It's very slight.
It's eccentric anyway in this exercise, but it doesn't matter.
If you want to train your speed, your rate of force development, which is crucial in arm wrestling, one of the most important things that people just aren't conscious of, you can do it in different ways, much more effectively for the sport. The only thing this training can really affect is this very short period, like zero to fifty milliseconds.
One hundred milliseconds is already too much.
This is the first twentieth of a second.
This may help you in this time frame to contract your muscles faster.
Again, you're doing that from an already contracted position.
Is it effective?
We can discuss.
I didn't see any studies about that, you know.
This is a debatable subject, but this is the only thing that potentially this training can do.
Do you really benefit from zero to fifty milliseconds?
It is important for sure, but I would say the most important would be zero to one hundred or zero to two hundred milliseconds.
So, in general, taking into account all the costs of this exercise
and the tool that's acting on your tendons, the risk of injury, and its effectiveness for arm wrestling, I would judge this exercise as probably as low as possible, unless we're going to find real justification to work from zero to fifty milliseconds' time range of contraction, and have proof that this actually works.
Because if you are isometrically attached to the chain, for example, and you go at maximum effort, you also train zero to fifty milliseconds. You also train it. You just do it in a safer way.
You also train it.
You just do it in a safer way.
So, yeah, so I think that's it for this video, and see you soon.
Bye.